[Music]
you had such an amazing year last year
and lot of people were talking about
this breakout year that you had what was
so different about last season how did
you did you approach the game
differently I was just having more fun I
think that's the main thing is going out
there having fun you know 2010 I was you
know pressing a little bit in trying too
hard you know just kind of relaxed been
playing this game since I was four years
old so you know it's it's not easy but
it's fun and you know as long as I
continue to smile and I'm having fun I'm
gonna be balling so I'm gonna continue
to have fun well it feels like there's
almost there's there's a little bit of a
battle between a hitter and a picture
where you're trying to get into your
rhythm and they're doing everything they
can to break you're with them you like
to take your time get ready are there
pictures that really trying to char you
up they try to rush you trying to get
you off your time and you know you got
to step out the box look at the umpire
and be like Oh time out I make it this
is my box this is my area this is me I
own this slow down you should actually
furnish it while you're out there you
you have you work really hard
and-and-and you work very hard on your
conditioning I saw a clip that just blew
me away I saw this on YouTube it's
you're doing a wheelbarrow exercise and
this is where this is where you go to
the top of the stairs on your hands and
then you do you follow that up with
push-ups without taking a break 70 push
the most I've done is 70 to 75 push-ups
something like that let me just take a
take a look at this because this is part
of my regimen as well
yeah those stairs are high - yeah I
might've did 50 right here look at those
arms
[Applause]
I feel bad for the guy who's holding
your legs all day yes that's actually
that's actually the that's actually the
hardest part is carrying the person up
writer than doing that so can you do
that you could probably do that me
that's Andy holds my legs and I go up I
think 900 stairs is it today 900
whatever you say yeah and then I do and
then you got to carry him yeah and then
I do we both to ten thousand sit-ups and
then we do we do water ballet for a
while you just swim around each other in
a pool that's interesting yeah yellow
we're gonna hit each other with pillows
and giggle the other where y'all wear
the bathing suits and everything huh
yeah we have a good time
sounds and maybe you should join us I
like to swim with women
[Applause]
whatever we don't know you're missing
the Dodgers
welcome to pirates in their home opener
tomorrow that's airing on the MLB
Network and MLB Major League Baseball 12
the show is which uh he's available now
on PlayStation 3 I thought there was
more than that there was something cool
but that's cool
PlayStation 3 and that's definitely
that's an awesome game yeah it's an
awesome game you went as the number s
the number one sports a video game in
for the past four years for PlayStation
this is great I love uncover you're on
the cover and I'm told that you guys
almost went with this cover decided not
to
[Applause]
how do you like how do you like my
what are you laughing at done singing my
form is incredible it's a very game very
great